what's up everybody procedure mad Luigi
here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel legendary weapon guide today
we're gonna be looking at the long nail
which is a legendary sniper rifle we're
gonna be looking how to get it at what
it is and how it does so it is a Vlad
off legendary incendiary sniper rifle
you see I have the bullshi long nailed
[ __ ] you just being the prefix to
the long nail which is the actual name
of the gun the red text is that it
nailed it
I think the bull Shi signifies that has
increases in crease increased ability be
[ __ ] increases stability and the
what makes this a legendary is that it
the shots penetrate shields that means
any enemy you encounter that has fields
doesn't matter to this gun this gun will
shoot through those shields and only
look at the enemy's health bar which is
really good for killing enemies a lot
faster that's what makes it so great and
also it ability its ability to kill fast
because it's flat off it does have a
high fire rate you can see its fire rate
is five point seven and magazine size is
29 for sniper that means that if you
have the standard amount of ammo that
can be held in sniper rifle so you
haven't upgraded at all with moonstone
from the crazy roll shop then you're
gonna run out of ammo really really
quickly with a sniper rifle even
upgrading your sniper rifle ammo to the
max you still run this sniper uses ammo
fast but it does kill things really
really quickly so like now this sniper
rifle spawns from The Sentinel which is
the final boss in the game however I
don't think it drops from his normal
version it only drops from this raid
boss version so once you beat him saying
you normally play through door true
vault hunter mode play through you're
gonna go to that board that you saw me
go to and you're gonna get the mission
to kill him as a raid boss and so you
get that you travel to LSC right where
he's at once you do this mission then
you'll be able to kill him as a raid
boss but if you don't do if you don't
pick up this mission you won't be able
to kill him as a raid boss until you
pick it up so you're gonna go just hop
over to the start and place your 4
moonstone in each spot and then you're
gonna enter now I have this all sped up
since it's like I'm a higher level so
it's actually a pretty quick fight but
sometimes it can be
long some just tactics to go over when
he's in this his first state you're
gonna want to shoot at him when he's not
doing his little arm flicky technique
jump over his splashes when he changed
his stances and basically just jump
around and shoot him that's the best
tactic to kill him wait till he stopped
spinning his arm around and shoot him
when he's just attacking you or doing
anything that's not doing his weapon
spin now you see you'll get the spawn
the bigger version of him the I forget
what it's called the Empyrean Sentinel
and you see I still kill it crazy fast
so fast that he doesn't get to the
stance of some things he does so you see
he'll knock you into the sky he'll shoot
you so he'll do those like giant stalks
of things and he'll also turn the ground
like electricity or whatever Kuro damage
when he's corroding and he'll make
platforms that appear so you're gonna
just want to hop on those when that
appears and yes basically so you'll see
I actually didn't get it from this but
this is just to kind of show you how to
do it what it's like killing the boss I
did get the drop and whoever recorded so
after this you'll see the actual drop so
you know I'm legit and that's the sniper
I didn't use at all because it is pretty
under leveled and I don't think it'd be
that good for this type of boss fight
excuse me but you see I'm a little 37
this knife is like a little like 28 and
I'm still using it I'm still using it up
to this level that's how good the sniper
rifle is like it just destroys so many
people so I really I really highly
recommend the sniper and you see this is
from my playthrough before I killed the
Raven stop the sniper I only so I oh
yeah as I said I only killed the raid
boss once so I killed it one time
normally and one time as a raid boss and
then I got it so it's and I've heard
other people getting it only from the
raid boss version so I'm pretty sure
it's confirmed special drop from him he
can drop other Legendary's but I think
this is his main legendary job now we're
gonna get into some gameplay of me
killing people with it this is on true
vault hunter mode the first time you
face a deadlift yeah deadlift he I
didn't expect him to hide his fat he
died so fast just unimaginable
all right so you see the cutscene and
you know watch me go into my Nisha
showdown skill and just kill him already
ready he's dead
he's dead it took took six shots six
bullets no mo maybe a little more but it
just killed so fast with Nisha this
Gunderson's Nisha is better with snipers
and pistols whose gun just destroys you
can see I just demolished that entire
room of people with like a showdown now
we have a Symetra and then but it just
this gun demolishes especially if you
get crits it goes to work so I really
highly suggest the sniper I do think
it's a very good sniper it's definitely
worth farming him a few times since I
think he does a pretty good job rate of
it Orly maybe I'm just super lucky
because it just destroys so many people
so quickly aye aye that's why I
recommend it so I think that's gonna be
it for this video
basically just where to get it how to
get it and how amazing it is it is a
really good sniper rifle and I do not
think it's hard to get since you can
that killing the sentinel isn't that
hard especially if you get a few levels
above them so I hope you all enjoyed
this video make sure you be on the
lookout on my channel for more legendary
guides and make sure you check out my
previous one which is how to get the
thingy it's a Crow's rocket launcher and
I appreciate you watching see you later
guys